you know what i find amazing about you
yo you have a writing partner yeah and
you're real successful as a writer and
you've got a production company and i
read something like you guys just sold
four shows or something in production is
that right
yeah we have a few pilots that were
trying to get made so you're really
successful at writing all this and the
guy who's your writing partner this kid
evan goldberg you met him when you were
12 out of bar mitzvah yeah bar mitzvah
class we met at bar mitzvah class and
and and it's amazing to me that you know
how old are you now 32. so from the time
you're 12 to the time you're 32 this kid
has become your writing partner you
would think
like most times that just wouldn't work
out you know what i mean it's really
weird
it is very
weird and it's not like lost on me that
we have like a very healthy
good working relationship with one
another i've seen a lot of partnerships
i know i mean obviously as a writer you
know other partner people who are in
partnerships and i've seen a lot of them
like evaporate even people who've been
together like for years and years and
years and years and years yeah some of
the great comedy teams they've all
broken up it's just almost impossible to
know someone since 12 and and do you
ever get like well maybe there are
better people at this for me maybe i'll
go right with this one or that one
you'll never get that one i've never
that's literally never even occurred to
me
ever um no we we like really get along
we work really well together we
i mean and now that we're directing
movies together like i think it's like
if it's a whole new thing that we're
it's like a whole new horizon when you
direct a movie with another guy can you
get in each other's way at all
very rarely like we'll have like
short intense disagreements at times but
i'd say
95 of the time we're totally on the same
page and like in the
we we kind of have all the arguments
that we would have before the filming of
the movie starts and you know what's
kind of cool too i would think directing
another person is also kind of securing
in a way because you've got at least
somebody you can bounce off especially
if you don't know how to do something
totally and you that you can talk about
it and you you can instantly get like a
little consensus and it's uh yeah it's i
would be really nervous doing it alone
honestly